millions of possible futures billions
advance maybe this is the reason I was
given powers we've got to stop you from
vanishing we've changed the future
before we can change it again the Barry
I know would never stop running he would
find another way to fight so when we do
first earth one my name is Cisco Ramon
want to tell me why the hell you were
time travelling to begin with and you
need to see this crisis for myself all I
don't understand you Barry
you march towards death without fear
where is it you gain strength
people I love
so it's finished your and woman our
badges
they're symbols of the strength that
we're charged with when we hear the call
of duty we're willing to make that
sacrifice oh we just ran out of time
we can't stop what's coming I have to
prepare the team for this crisis maybe
even a world without the flash
you have great power even though you've
been raised as a human being you are not
one of them welcome back everyone it's
Charlie we have a brand new flash season
six crisis on Infinite Earths trailer to
breakdown we have a brand new look at
Brandon Ralph as kingdom comes Superman
on set actually filming scenes we've
seen a couple pictures of his costume
but we haven't seen him actually filming
stuff yet there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs we have a pretty good idea
of what's going on the first couple of
episodes and we're doing that new flash
ring giveaway - all you have to do to
enter just be a subscriber and leave
your best theory about crisis on
Infinite Earths on the video I'll name a
new winner at the end of this even
though they haven't confirmed it there
are some Easter eggs in the background
that seemed to imply that they're doing
baby John Kent that's Tyler hoechlin
Superman's son we can only hope that
they'll do a version of the scene from
the boys where someone uses the baby's
laser eyes because remember John Kent's
Superboy has the same powers as Superman
[Music]
oh how it was diabolical make all the
diabolical joke Siwan so what it seems
like they're doing with this flash
trailer is that they're including
footage from the first couple of
episodes because there's a whole bunch
more Jay Garrick with Barry on earth
three because everything looks really
old-timey inside his version of STAR
Labs if you're a big fan of the 90s
flash series I would be willing to bet a
lot of money that there's gonna be a lot
of Easter eggs and props from that 90s
Flash series inside his version of STAR
Labs the reason why you know that is his
is because everything looks really
old-timey and art deco and obviously
there's the other version of the woman
that looks just like Barry's mother
who's probably Joan Garrick Jay
Garrick's wife I love his dialogue -
Barry
why were you time-traveling again you
had one job one job I told you back in
season three no more time-traveling do I
need to pull out the coffee cup again so
it seems like it's pretty clear that in
the first episode the monitor shows up
he rolls into the club to STAR Labs and
maybe destroys Gideon because it looks
like it's blowing up after this big
scene giving Barry the same speech that
he gave to Oliver that the crisis is
coming you need to be forewarned so
they're looking at the future newspaper
that Nora showed them last season and
the one that they've been looking at
this whole time
flash vanishes in crisis a lot of you
have also asked why it says 2024 in
these scenes but at the end of last
season we got that season five post
credit scene where it rolled down like a
demonic countdown clock to 2019 so why
doesn't it say 2019 in this scene either
it's going to do that at some point
during the episode or they just did that
at the post-credits scene last year just
to let you know that crisis was
happening this year but it seems like
the big plot of the first episode is
Barry travelling to the future to
actually quote-unquote see this crisis
for myself then realizing whatever it's
happening in these flash-forward scenes
that there's nothing that he can do to
save it and he's destined to die it's
like a fixed point in time you get that
shot of him in the bed inside that new
version of STAR Labs typically when they
go to other earths they also tint the
video just a little bit different so
that you know you're in a different
environment they kind of do that for
people that don't pay attention to how
they travel the multiverse
there's
shot of them looking for a particular
device that's cut with a Chester P runks
scene so this might have something to do
with him it might be completely
different because they also have a
villain montage with a couple different
villains some of them returning some of
them looking like they're new it's not
really clear where this scene of bury
and killer frost in the hospital are
there's a couple different Hospital
scenes he keeps talking about traveling
to the future but there's nothing in
this scene that indicates that it's
actually happening in the future
it's not clear if Jay Garrick shows up
in the first episode though because he's
only credited on the second episode so
all of this footage might actually be
from the second episode this scene of
Caitlin looking like she's getting
sucked into some kind of vortex with the
flash running by might be from the
flash-forwards when Barry is looking at
crisis in the future or it could have
something to do with that transonic Dee
molecular Iser that they have that
picture of but I know a lot of you were
actually talking about the people in his
chat there that are trying to cheer him
on Pizza Parker obviously a reference to
spider-man they referenced the Hulk and
spider-man across several different
seasons and say their names out loud so
apparently it's totally cool for them to
do stuff like that I think where they
draw the line on stuff like that where
Marvel and DC and Warner Brothers is
where people actually start wearing
shirts so like Cisco couldn't walk in
wearing a spider-man t-shirt they would
get really pissed off about that but
really when you think about it it's
almost like free advertising for Marvel
and if the Marvel characters and one of
their TV shows ever referenced Superman
it would be like free advertising for DC
the other one says everyone's favorite
Rob Dante the man Star Wars for life
obviously Star Wars has been referenced
several times on the flash TV series so
we know that DC Comics exists Marvel
Comics exists in Star Wars exist within
the world of Earth 1 there's a whole
bunch more killer frost scenes you see
her going to town on the STAR Labs dummy
they did say that this was supposed to
be the season of killer frost like
really big season for her character so
she'll mostly be starting out dealing
with the trauma from losing her father
last season more of that scene with the
new version of Welles zip-lining in
throttling Cisco there have been people
on the set of the flash where they film
stuff that say that he's supposed to
have an Australian accent remember Joe
West is the new police captain so it
seems like he's leaning on Ralph to sort
of give these announcements and he's
taking a more active role so elongated
man is also supposed to meet sue Dib
knee sometime this season but she's
obviously not
Sudipta yet she has a different name
because she hasn't gotten married to
Ralph yet so we'll meet that person at
some point during the season we get a
couple new scenes with the blood work
villain talking to Barry I don't get it
why do you keep running into the face of
death knowing that you might die well
that's because he's a hero that feels
like a stupid question to ask but all
these scenes of him seem pretty tame so
this is probably before he breaks bad at
some point because the blood work
villain is only around for the first
half of the season and his arc will help
T up crisis whatever their final battle
winds up being it probably happens in
that episode aid you get the villain
montage so obviously this is the new
version of Harrison wells but then
Norwalk is back from season four
breacher is back I love that he breaches
in on Cisco and his new girlfriend while
they're in bed this person almost looks
like golden glider but I don't think
that that's her she might just be
another new villain the debuts during
the season Cisco tells Barry the new
suit is ready he gets his brand new suit
even though technically he's wearing it
through almost all the scenes in this
video really liked the new enhanced cowl
if you guys didn't know they didn't just
bring the chin back they flared the
Lightning earpieces out way more just
like the comics in the entire cowl is
made from a completely different
material that looks a little more
breathable and it fits his face way
better than the cowl from last season so
just all-around on all levels the
costume looks better there's a scene of
Barry interrogating a prisoner inside
the pipeline prison who then breaks out
that might have something to do with the
god speed scene but because Barry is
travelling to the future to see crisis
that also might have something to do
with him seeing God speed or maybe God
speed follows him back from the future
when he comes back still not clear where
this version of God speed comes from
because technically they erased the
future that Nora came from so either
he'd have to be from a new future that's
created part of this whole crisis arc or
he'd have to be from somewhere in the
multiverse then get a little tag for
Brandon Roth Superman from Superman
Returns in Tom Welling Superman from
Smallville so if it wasn't clear the
scenes that they're filming right now
with Brandon raus Kingdom Come
Superbrand who's obviously slightly
older than he was during Superman
Returns with grey streaks seems like
it's still happening on the Supergirl
episode of the crossover I still think
that they're filming that first episode
because of all the Tom Welling scenes
that we got last week too we also know
that his Superman jumps to earth 38 some
time during that first episode of the
crossover every
post your crisis theories in the
comments below The Joker movie is coming
out this weekend be sure to go see it my
review video will post later tonight
I'll do ester eggs all those videos this
weekend
congratulations Jevon ham you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details
everybody click here for all my other
flash season 6 crisis on Infinite Earths
trailer videos and click here for my
non-spoilery joker movie review thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Applause]
you